evening this is a horrific day for the
Commonwealth of Virginia our hearts ache
over the senseless violence that has
been inflicted upon the Virginia Beach
community today my deepest condolences
and prayers go to the families of those
who left home this morning and will not
return tonight they were all someone's
child and many were someone's parent
they were heading into the summer
weekend that they should be taken in
this manner is the worst kind of tragedy
their families are facing painful loss
and grief they each leave a hole in a
family in their neighborhood in this
community and in our Commonwealth
we mourn with their loved ones but
sympathy doesn't fill that hole we must
take care of these families these
horrific tragedies test our souls grief
doesn't pass quickly it lasts far beyond
these coming days and these families
will need support in the months and
years to come
I'm also praying for those who were
injured in this tragedy and hoping for
their full recovery along with the pain
of their own injuries they face the loss
of their co-workers and their friends I
want to commend the local and state law
enforcement officers the first
responders the medical teams and all
others who acted swiftly to respond to
this situation their accidents likely
saved lives and they have experienced
scenes and injuries no one should ever
have to face my thoughts continue to be
with the victims and their families
to them and to the city of Virginia
Beach I offer the full support of the
Commonwealth of Virginia tonight we are
all about Virginia Beach I'd like now
I'd like to turn the podium over to our
mayor of Virginia Beach mayor Dyer today
is for jr. Beach's darkest hour a
senseless crime happened and imposed
tremendous grief upon the people of
Virginia Beach the Commonwealth and this
country when we get through the shock of
it all and we get through the details
that we must go through over the next
day or two I believe that our community
Virginia Beach along with our neighbors
and our other cities in Hampton Roads
and our Commonwealth and our country
will be there for not only the families
because that's when they're going to
need us going forward but we're going to
show that Virginia Beach is a city of
resolve and dedication and you know we
are going to be there for all the
families the friends and our community
in a big way and for that I thank you
and I would like to turn this over to
chiefs of ever for an update
as I said earlier this evening as we are
able to gather more information we will
give that information out so this is the
additional information that I have at
this time again that will probably
change a little and it may increase as
we move forward as we're investigating
this case right now we have a team of
investigators detectives from the city
of Virginia Beach being assisted by
forensic technicians from the FBI and
the State Police in processing this most
horrific scene we are in the process of
identifying the victims and making
notification for their families I can
tell you that we do have an additional
victim to report we now have 12 one
victim succumbed to the injuries on the
way to the hospital we also have four
additional victims being treated at area
hospitals and we have reports that
others may have self transported so as
we get more information on that we will
begin to release it our process is
always to notify family members prior to
releasing names we do know who the
suspect is we have not been successful
in notifying certain family members once
we are able to do that we will release
his name once we're going to mention his
name once and then he will be forever
referred to as the suspect because our
focus now is the dignity and respect to
the victims in this case and to their
families I can tell you that when the
initial call came out of an active
shooter on a building to building number
two in our city houses information
technology planning public works of
public utilities plus the printing
operation there this building has the
potential of having over 400 city
workers at one time or other in the
building when the original call came out
immediately four officers responded to
our seasoned veteran supervisors from
the detective bureau
and we have to k-9 handlers who are
assigned to our special operations unit
they immediately made entry into the
building due to the sound of gunfire
they were able to locate the floor in
which the suspect was committing his
carnage they immediately engaged with
the suspect and I can tell you that it
was a long gun battle between those four
officers in that suspect we've recovered
a 45 caliber handgun with multiple
extended magazines that were emptied at
the time the suspect was reloading
extended magazines in that handgun
firing at victims throughout the
building and at our officers I want you
to know that during this gun battle
basically the officer stopped this
individual from committing more carnage
in that building when the suspect went
down due to due to his injuries all
officers then immediately rendered first
aid as they were removing him from the
building to the waiting EMS personnel
and I need to say that a second time
even though he involved he was involved
in in a long-term moving gun battle with
these officers when he went down they
did what cops do and they rendered
first-date to this individual he
succumbed to his wounds we have found
victims on all three floors of the
building as one Vic as well as one
victim who was outside in a vehicle
right now as many as 90 people of sought
support from the family assistance
center and again we are in the process
our goal now is to identify everyone in
that building as quick as we can so we
can make the proper notifications to the
families of those victims do we have any
questions
I mean that's the relation but what do
you say with a vehicle as an
individual's in his vehicle when the
suspect shot him I have no information
at this time as to the background of the
individual other than he's a city
employee again as we work through all of
this we'll be able to give more
information at a later he was that's
correct there was one victim outside he
entered the building he was armed with a
45 caliber handgun that had a suppressor
on it I'm sorry
there were extended magazines in other
words they have more ammunition than the
regular magazine we have 12 victims and
a deceased suspect G for any of the
victims targeted at this time I I can't
comment on that as we work through the
investigation I cannot give you that
because we are in the process of
identifying the victims yes
well I originally reported we had eleven
victims we have an additional one victim
did not succumb to the wounds on the way
to the hospital or at the hospital and I
am told that we have four others at the
hospital right now going through
surgeries well your math would would say
that we had 12 deceased I did and again
that was the information that I had at
that time it's been updated right we
have 12 deceased and we have four orange
going through yes going through surgery
we're in the process of continuing our
investigation at this time and we're at
the product we're in the process of
continuing you that's the best I'm going
to be able to tell you at this moment
I could tell you that there was numerous
shots fired by the individual shots were
fired from various places down the
hallway that the officers at one time
returned well basically they're there
the ammunition that they had so when we
talk about this kind of a situation and
many times when we talk about an
officer-involved shooting situation it
may be minimal rounds by the suspect and
by the police officers this was well
beyond that this was a long time but the
best I could describe it this was a long
term gun battle for police office I
can't I can't give you seconds and
minutes because we don't you know we
don't have a stopwatch when we we're
engaged in this I'm sorry
shortly after we entered the building
and confronted him so the the call came
out it right after 4:00 p.m. so would be
somewhere after that we don't have the
exact time the individual in question is
an employee he has access to the
building he came in with a weapon today
one officer did sustained a wound during
the gun battle fortunately his
bulletproof vest basically saved his
life and we did he was seen he was
tended to at the scene but then we then
brought him to the hospital afterwards
to make sure that everything is okay
with the office
it's a suppressor it's a sound
suppressor we're working through ATF at
this time it's part of our investigation
we train continuously we train not only
as first responders for police but we
train with fire and we train with our
EMS personnel because we know that when
you have a major scene like this you're
going to need all first responders into
that particular area so we do train
extensively both on what we call
tabletop exercises as well as on all
hands on exercise in a building so I can
tell you that we do train extensively
and how many weeks or months prior I
can't give you the exact number but our
officers and our EMS personnel and our
fire personnel are highly qualified
unfortunately in a situation of an
active shooter case of k9 that's correct
okay thank you um just one final thing
and I've said it before and you heard
the governor and mayor speak of it we
have numerous victims and we have
numerous families let's make sure that
we keep their dignity and their respect
as the number one piece of news that
we're going to give out and I know that
our local media always abides by because
their lives have changed forever the
folks who work in that building their
lives have changed I have a number of
officers right now who are processing
through what gusts could be described as
a warzone their lives are going to be
changed
quick question Mandarin hands are any
because of this involved city employees
or any city services and going to be
affected by all of this I mean obviously
every one of your employees s to be
grieving just I know something works got
to go on but how's that being handled